[Music]
okay so this is for my friend Damien I'm
going to explain to him a little bit
about lettering because he is lettering
my new comic I and become pestilence and
he's having a bit of a hard time with it
so in order to help put some of his
fears to rest about the project I'm
gonna go through what I think is a very
good example of lettering and comics and
help him learn a little so dear Damien
Brian Michael Bendis writes a bajillion
words per panel
he writes entire paragraphs in every
single panel and being a letter ER on
one of his books would probably be a
[ __ ] nightmare so let's go through a
couple of pages written by Bendis and
see what works about the lettering
because it may not always look like
there's enough space in every single
panel for what needs to be said or what
needs to be done but a good letter
esteem an a go-to letter boy always
finds a way so what I'm noticing here is
that already this letter he did this is
very you know simple trick of just
pacing it out basically sentence by
sentence or at least you know grouping
together to here but he he put it in
this pattern so that it kind of arcs
around the the art so you start out here
up in this negative space where there's
really nothing and it kind of curves
around Peters foot and follows back to
his face the it almost tells you a
little bit of a story it's like it's
almost like a slow pan but visual where
you start up here looking at nothing and
then your eye follows the art all the
way down here to his face the emotional
focal point center of this panel you
know there's a lot of emotion there so
we start with his thoughts it's it's
almost like imagining a camera in a
movie starting aimed at a wall and then
slowly panning over to the face of the
character as he's monologuing
obviously here it's a panel they gave a
lot of space for all this you know it's
just giving a little bit of text for
every single bubble and you know the
thing about the bubbles is that they
don't often ever really touch the edges
even on this one it would be really easy
to have that one be touching the edge
captions I think usually do the general
rule for them is that they always stay
kind of floating in the middle because
captions are is meant to convey a voice
an inner voice so I think it's it's
important that is as a few times as
possible they don't actually touch the
edges of the art because that it just
kind of solidifies them it almost makes
them seem less like they're floating on
top of the situation and more attached
to it physically well as with dialogue I
think the reason that's able to touch
the borders is because the dialogue is
being spoken outs out loud it's it's
more of a a a physical part of the scene
you know it can be heard it can be felt
the dialogue is a sound less than a
abstract thought
now here you might see all of this like
if I were to type all of this out you
would see it as as just this brick of
text on on the script and it would say
you know panel 1 2 3 4 would say panel 4
and have all this text and you'd look at
this and you go where the [ __ ] do I put
this what I shove all of it up here in
one single box let's go check what that
is oh look that's you Damian do you see
that that's you in the past any way
you'd look at all this and think which
part do I shove all of it in but you
just break it up and then just kind of
follow along lines of the art it's it's
always kind of following curves I think
I can actually draw in this program I'm
recording so yeah look you follow the
curves you find the dead space and then
kind of draw inside of there it's it's a
handy trick you know so let's move on to
an
Paige alright so this one I really
picked this one because I like the way
does the thought captions now for this
one it's supposed to be kind of panicked
and scared and frightened
you know he's his thoughts are a little
bit scattered so they're literally
scattered in several boxes there they're
quick little snippets of information
this can't be spinning going to can't
see straight
like all of this is put into tiny little
boxes because they're all tiny little
thoughts zooming by in his head all at
once they're you know kind of just quick
little moments it's not a giant single
thought it's not one big box over off to
the side here with all of this stuck
inside of it cuz then it would look kind
of cheesy and weird but you know the
stylized stylization of it here all of
this the way it's broken up helps it to
feel a little bit more important and it
just kind of it helps with the panic of
this situation because he's been shot
he's running away from the cops you know
okay so dialogue two people talking I
like this example because it's a very
small little scene everyone's you know
they're not giving each other giant
speech it's just a little bit of a you
know he says one thing he says another
very short sentences and you know really
the thing about it is that I'd notice if
it's possible to make the word bubble
round they always go for it you can't
quite make it a perfect circle around
around just the word and but if you have
just a couple of words usually it's
pretty round yeah they don't have very
you don't often see very you know like
like this this bubble you it's it's very
oval-shaped
and elongated and horizontal that's
because it's it's clustered around a
single word that's a little bit longer
than you know like three letters up here
so that's why this one's shaped this way
but a sentence that has about four words
is still almost a perfect circle he
stacks them in a way that
just you know gets it as rounded as
possible it's it's not kind of elongated
horizontally you try to avoid that as
much as possible because the elongated
horizontal board bubbles or they just
tend to look kind of off you know it's
just kind of the rule that you don't go
for them as much as you can
sure you might see them here and there
but it's still you know you you tend to
try to avoid them now here is just an
example of like stylization to help the
scene work is just making the though you
could write this is just plain text but
it makes it so much more impactful to
have it kind of blasting out of the
bubble like this like I see this all the
time where they shape around the letter
as it kind of explodes out of the you
know the the exterior of it but then as
her her laughter and the way she's
talking calms down
it sort of chills out here and is a
little bit more you know rounded out
standard word bubble so you just
consider that for when you know
someone's yelling or or something crazy
is happening there you want to really
emphasize something being said now here
is another example of captioning in a
very clustered big crazy scene like you
notice how there's probably a ton of
stuff behind this this little word
bubble or this this caption box here
unfortunately we don't get to see what a
lot of that is but thing is it doesn't
matter it's just background stuff you
know these people they don't matter
their lives are small they're boring
people they don't matter this is
spider-man he's a god among men look at
this man this man has seen death he's
killed people on accident but still he's
done it this man he's gone to other
worlds look at him shoving that candy
bar in his mouth like nothing's ever
happened this man there's an alien that
lived on his skin he met God yet an
actual conversation with God he he he
had lunch with him once he yelled at him
a lot
these are the eyes of a man who doesn't
have a wife anymore because of Satan
anyway all this stuff back here all
these other people they don't really
matter so you just kind of you know for
background characters you can just kind
of put word boxes and letters and all
that over them because it doesn't matter
and up here I like this really creative
use of this space because he has was
this like three sentences to say and
instead of trying to put it in this big
block of text right up here over you
know a whole chunk of her face
he just paces it out and strings it
along the top so you just kind of follow
it along you know is there's a very
creative use of the dead space because
if you look at your focal point you know
is there's this thing where he's
thinking about what this chick says so
her she's kind of running through his
mind literally instead of putting any of
the word bubbles over her because she is
a focal point basically this this is all
just a like everything through here is
like a dead zone that you can't
necessarily put art in maybe in here if
you could get away with it so he goes
for the method of trying to put it more
up top also over here since there's a
little bit bigger of a gap between her
and herself and also you don't get to
see the face of this one so it's not
really a focal point you know it's just
trying to figure out the best spots to
put it the way it doesn't cover over the
main focus the image because the thing
is you got to remember that not every
single part of your art is going to be
necessary you have to look for what is
the most important thing and focus on
that Peter is the most important thing
in these panels also this chick looking
back at him
maybe that has some kind of significance
to the story you know there's also
Jameson back here you just find the
space that isn't one of these people and
yes it kind of covers over his shoulder
and you know it's not over here so he's
looking at the word bubble so you have
to take into account little things like
that so it doesn't look like either of
them are looking at a word bubble so
they put it over here over on his
shoulder it's just being
is creative and thoughtful as you
possibly can about the placement okay
now this one this spot I want to
highlight down here I really like this
little chunk here because this is a lot
of dialogue for a panel that gives you
no [ __ ] space if you if you looked at
the script for this and saw this amount
of dialogue and then saw this panel I'm
sure you'd like lose your [ __ ] it would
be so frustrating but they came up with
a method to do it anyway because like I
said there is always a way
you know don't ever give up and go
there's no room there's always room so
without even really intruding too badly
on the art of this panel because you
still see these people all on the ground
all smoking all messed up and beat up
from the fight you still see that the
focal point of them is still there as
well as them fighting in the back they
hooked all of the dialogue along this
little border here because the border
isn't important you know it's it's empty
space you don't put it in the in the
margins because then that'll just make
it impossible to print but you can kind
of cheat it along the the the little top
of the box here you know it's creative
placement okay this one I thought was an
interesting panel because he has a lot
to say and not a lot of room to say it
so the the letterer for this issue kind
of curved his speech around his head in
a way that you know because you're
always leading reading these word
bubbles left to right and usually they
traditionally they kind of go down you
know that's how you read comics as you
read them left to right and down so they
treated the word bubbles the same way
you read it left to right and down the
first one goes up here second one goes
down here the another indication of the
placement is that this one's lower than
this one they did the same exact thing
so you're kind of your eye is tracing it
along all the way to here almost the
same way that we were talking about that
speech at the that first page we showed
is the way it kind of pans down to his
face it starts at this empty
spot up here and then creatively just
kind of takes you right back to the
focal point because I think um
Bagley I don't know if he necessarily
intended for it to be lettered this way
but he did leave a little bit of space
up here along Electro's head it's not
dead center of the panel so I think he
either intended for maybe the word
bubbles to be along here or something
but I like the way it was done in that
it follows down this way because it just
it just it tracks your high it's it's
you know basic is basic art tricks
really is you got to lead the eye of the
person that's that's reading it same way
as you know like graphic design you
gotta make sure that the focal point of
your image is easy to figure out you
track your audience there and even here
they do the same sort of stuff as a
there's a lot of dialog per panel but
you figure it out I picked this one
because I noticed that this guy he
throws in his little little piece for
the conversation here and it actually
cuts off the top of flash Thompson's
head but you know you can still see
flash Thompson's face his emotion is
still prevalent the the conversation is
not being disrupted because there's not
a big crazy word bubble on his face you
don't really notice that it's on top of
his hair because you know his hair isn't
like the most important thing in the
world you should always with something
they tell you in film school is to
always edit based on emotion cut on a
motion first in continuity second so
sometimes you know like you cut from one
shot to the next and the person sitting
in a slightly different way but it was
both it was both you know the best takes
it cuts from best take of this line to
the best take of that line you don't cut
to a worst take just because he was
sitting the same way in both of them you
use the best ones the way the actor was
acting you're editing around the
performance so it's kind of a similar
rule is that you know sometimes you you
have to cut and you have to you have to
do these these letters not based on
what's going to preserve the art the
best but what's going to preserve
the the emotion the best now everyone's
face is important to keep as open as
possible you know when he's talking you
need to see his face you need to see his
emotions you know he looks a little
concerned she looks a little you know
kind of I don't know if I want to answer
that question right and it's okay if his
head is a little cutoff up here you
don't don't make a habit of it but it's
it's not the biggest problem I noticed
with here this could easily be one big
word bubble but they kind of split it up
just to accentuate what he's saying
sometimes you have to really really pay
attention to what's being said in the
dialogue itself and think about the way
to let her at rhythmically so that it
kind of emphasizes the beats of the
sentence because he's going hey you ever
think like what if in ghostbusters like
like there's this pause when he's kind
of enunciated that he has this idea he's
trying to get their attention then it
leads into this this bigger point you
know it's it's it's just a little subtle
trick that I like that they use there
and you know of course there's a lot of
dialogue for this panel but he still
finds a way to get it all in and still
figures out a way to curve it there's a
lot of question mark shaped lettering in
this series and it's done by all
different letterers I'm not telling you
to emulate one single person I actually
checked and that's why there's different
type of thought bubbles here versus here
is because the different letterers
because there are several issues apart
so you know you got to look for tricks
wherever you can and then of course you
know there's stuff like this is a
there's a lot of empty space up above
MJ's head and they just you know kind of
rhythmically flow through one little
piece to the next so that you get all
this dialogue in here this is a good
spot and you know this stuff this really
makes the scream really you know loud
it looks visually loud
stylize this stuff but this one's us
these are smaller noises it's not quite
you know the same impact emphasis is
this panel so they're slightly taken
back it's just you know again contacts
base think about the art and the script
and how this would sound out loud here I
really like the way they they did this
because look at this panel right it has
enough Headroom for a little bit of
lettering but I believe this is I I
think it's it's um Mary Parker yeah
Richard Parker's wife has a giant speech
to give in just this panel right the
script I'm sure says your panel is a
very complicated layout but but look at
all that could you imagine if I wrote a
script to you and then sent it and I
told you to fit all of that in just this
tiny box it's impossible but there's
still a way to do it so I like the way
this one the way it bleeds across from
this panel all the way down to this one
you start with what he's saying and then
as she goes into her whole speech it it
kind of you know tracks your eye from
this panel down to this one it also
helps with the layout because you know
some people might have a hard time
figuring out where to go next from one
art piece to the next you know from one
panel to the next so you know lettering
can help trace you along the page it
kind of helps you follow and her whole
speech is given here almost like it's
you know being said off screen and then
you cut to this part and it you know
it's actually interesting that you don't
ever actually see her face considering
what she's saying is so important so you
know just pay attention for stuff like
that if someone has a lot to say look
for any empty space you can use any at
all even if it's bleeding into another
panel if it can be used in a sort of
sense for flow you know you get this
panel to lead to this one it go for it
yeah his shoulder is not a very
important part of the image much like
his eyes meeting his this is still
preserved because these are the two
focal points his shoulder is not a focal
point you can cut that off so that's
that's fine this one I I picked to look
at just because it's you know just very
good use of all the negative space you
can find follow all the way down to here
you track track towards their face
don't cover other people's faces what is
going on with MJ's eye she looks like
the devil holy [ __ ] she's possessed by a
demon what the [ __ ] but anyway I you
know you just find whatever space you
can there's plenty up yet you don't need
to see this brick wall granted I'm sure
the color person or you know maybe
Bagley they put a lot of work into
making sure that brick wall was textured
and and it looks really nice but it's
not important she's important Gwen is
important you know maybe she's a little
bit of a pain in the neck sometimes but
um but you you got to make sure that
what she's saying is the focus so you
know you just cover up this there's this
really creative placement because all I
think all of this this text is it
wherever you can find space for it and
you know there's times where you just
follow the curvature of of the art it's
it's a really handy trick and you can
just make it look so pretty by doing
that now this is a very major thing and
I don't know if you know this rule but
when you have a paragraph of dialogue
always always always in any way you can
make it round even though that's that's
what's important about center aligning
the text is that you can have have it
curved let's let's show you here so you
know the text there's there's only one
there's only one word on this bottom
line you could probably fit two but the
placement of it was put in
way that it it fits in a little circle
you can what you place the text down
first as circle-shaped little blocks of
text then put the bubbles behind them
second the bubbles come second the text
goes first that's why you have to kind
of make it easy on yourself you make the
text shape like a circle as best you can
first sometimes it's harder sometimes
you may have to get this sort of
elliptical elongated bubble like I said
it's something you should try to avoid
but for this panel it seemed to be the
best way to fit all of that in here
without making it go up off into the
margin or cutting off her head so it was
just uh you know the way that he had to
use the space so it's just think about
that kind of stuff keep it as round as
possible and yeah again I also like how
how you know it tracks it follows along
because we get this really important
super emphasized panel and then already
we're being tracked along to the next
important thing and you know it's it's
about leading the eye you're kind of
you're kind of the tracks on the train
when it comes to comics you know you're
you're doing your best you can to
accentuate the art it should never look
out of place and I like you know this
this is a good use of space considering
what's available
a mature letter would probably try and
put it in the middle because you know
that's where they're talking right there
she's talking to him he's talking to her
I like the way it was done here where
you know there's an empty space behind
his head there's a whole chunk of this
panel that's not being used just put it
there there's a very good arch on her
back so you could just kind of trace
that line and follow down her her back
because there's this whole column of
nothing over here so this entire
conversation gets fitted in here someone
try and you know put it along the bottom
like this but I think this is a good use
of the empty space you're always trying
to figure out what's the best use of
your your negative space as well as
sometimes when it's necessary to have
the art concept cut something off this
is a giant annoying huge conversation
like look at all this there's so much
being said on this page I picked this
one because one two three four five six
seven eight nine panels my layouts I
usually try to keep them like six panels
max because like this is a nightmare to
draw especially also to letter but when
you have a time constraint you have to
get a certain amount of information
about and only 22 pages you may have to
do a layout like this where maybe you
combine two pages of four or five pages
and there are four or five panels into
one gigantic thing so I understand the
decision to do that here so this is a
big conversation I noticed that in order
to get this whole little chunk of text
it was placed on the back of her head
but the front of her face which is you
know with the spot where he's looking
the important part is still left empty
and this is negative space here but it's
not quite negative space where it would
fit you know he'd be staring at her word
bubble she'd be staring at nothing this
this sort of ominous cool look of
mysterion at mysteriousness she's doing
where they're eyeing each other down and
you know she's all shadowy that would be
kind of lost if you put it here so while
there is negative space it's not quite
appropriate negative space so it's
understandable why I would be on the
back of her head again not in the margin
never never in the margin no worse avoid
this there's also a creative space of a
creative placement of just following
along through here
you know just yeah track all the way
back to his mouth and you know it's cool
because it manages to show this other
character in the scene while also still
having your eye track through this so
even though you may not look at it that
way if it had the word bubbles you know
gone if you just took this
base art you'd probably only be looking
at at him but it you know it attracts
your eye so you end up seeing the the
background her him and her all because
the lettering it's almost like the
lettering is the movement of the camera
in a movie well as the the art is the
set building and the actors you know I
try to relate it back to filmmaking as
much as possible because that's what I
know um I like this little spot here is
just a nice stylization to tell you that
this is a staticky noise this is not
super Claire okay there's not there's
not a ton of clarity it's not super
clear that this is you know you could
tell this is coming from a TV just
because of the style is a ssin I like
this little little bit of continuity on
the bubbles where it doesn't break them
across his whole speech it actually has
the bubble tails going to his mouth
twice to give the impression that he is
going through this whole speech and you
kind of see you kind of see it in your
head the way he moves from this position
to this one while still talking the
whole time isn't it weird how Richard
Parker is drawn like 6-1-6 Peter Parker
I think that's a cool little detail that
that been that Bagley did because his
his Peter Parker is like really unique
doesn't look much like him that looks a
lot like 6-1-6 Peter Parker that's a
cool little detail his dad is his old
spider-man yeah whatever stupid don't
eat that
yeah his little stylisation sort of
sound effects I don't usually write a
ton of sound effects under my comics
because I feel like it's a little cheesy
you don't need them that much the art
can really speak for itself a lot of the
time and if you read like Punisher max
there isn't a single sound effect a
little you know addition at any point in
the whole series but you still get a
very strong feeling of what the art is
saying and what noises you should be
hearing just because it's so well stated
in the art
maybe if if you saw this you wouldn't
exactly see you know because the the bed
is a very small portion of this so you
just see her jumping maybe it looks like
she's jumping onto the bed or something
so the squeak gives you this impression
that she's jumped twice so yeah you know
I don't know if that was something
Bendis intended or if something the
letter are put there but it helps to
give a little extra context and make
things make sense I understand why
someone would do it again there's you
know shitload of text but you still
manage to get all of it on there and
yeah I just
same as always just like look through
pages of professional stuff and figure
out what you can learn from them I
noticed here on this page that there's
because there's so much he needs to say
in this very vertical column that it
would be hard to kind of track it along
the east side here so they kind of go
for you know putting it up up above him
and below him you don't actually see
what his hands are doing here and the
thing is is he really is it super
important because they're probably just
kind of clasped together or sitting in
his lap or something you know you don't
really need to see what his hands are
doing so it's okay to cover up certain
things like that just as long as the
focus of the images is because his face
you know he's tired he's depressed his
closer wrinkly he's in this this empty
dimly lit room but you still get enough
of that to understand the context in the
scene and what he's feeling and what
he's saying
what he what he's doing with his hands
down here isn't necessarily the most
important thing in the world so
sometimes you can cover the art in a
pretty significant amount like that
because maybe half of him plus whatever
is going on down here is cut off so you
know sometimes you have to wonder is it
super important what is the focal point
because it may not be his entire body on
the figure but just whatever's the mo
emotional part if someone's punching you
accentuate their fists if someone's
talking you look at their face you
always look at whatever is you know most
important for the emotion so his hands
are not some kind of important thing in
the scene you know there's not something
in them that the audience needs to see
you don't need to see it you just cover
it up word bulbs who gives you it right
it works and that brings us back to here
I really hope that this helped in some
way tell me if this is you know in any
way like something helpful or
educational I just thought I'd do this
since you know lettering is in a way
kind of an art form in and of itself and
people don't really give it that amount
of credit so I thought I would do this
to just help learn some of the tricks of
the trade because you get a bajillion
videos all over YouTube about how to
make a word bubble in Photoshop or like
what the most efficient way to do that
is or you know how to draw a certain
type of scene or you know how to color
something but when it comes to lettering
it's kind of scarce you don't you don't
get anything about the artistic side of
lettering because it is in art it's
something you can very easily screw up
and ruin a comic if it doesn't look
right so just to look at it as seriously
as you would any other part piece of the
process it's really almost the thing
that ties it all together is because you
have to make sure that every single word
that your writer put down makes it into
that page you can edit down you can't go
well there's too many there's too many
words in that sentence so I'm gonna cut
it down I'm gonna take out like you
don't cut out the word entire you don't
say the world hates me right because I
some idiot was running around you don't
cut this down to fit you just you put
all of it in there no matter how hard it
may seem there is always a way that's
the biggest rule of lettering and while
I may not exactly be an expert I think
I've you know been looking
enough comics I've read enough comics in
my life that I think I can get a pretty
good feel for just how to do at least
some of that stuff you know so let me
know if this was helpful and maybe I
should send something else for something
else you know like this it could be fun
thank you
bye now
[Music]
[Music]